sechs stunden waren sie aus dubai
unterwegs und jetzt kommen noch zwei
stunden im flughafen oben drauf aber
familie weiter trägt die geduldsprobe
die befragungen dokumenten checks gegen
jacks und den wer weiß wie vielten
corona test denn sie gehören zu den
ersten touristen die nun auf thailands
ferieninsel reisen dürfen
fast wie früher und ohne zwei wochen
quarantäne aber mit strengen auflagen
es gibt viel papierkram zu erledigen man
muss jede menge formulare ausfüllen und
dann sehr viele tests die ganz schön ins
geld geht
aber ich denke das ist auch sinnvoll
denn man will ja sicher sein
es sind wirklich eine menge tests nötig
aber ich denke auch dass es besser so
ist gerade auch für die kinder sandbox
sandkasten heißt das programm mit dem
thailand tourismusmanager den ruinen
abwenden wollen
nach 40 millionen besuchern 2009/10
brach das geschäft mit corona fast
vollständig zusammen
thailand erlebt die schlimmste krise
seit 20 jahren
deshalb werden phuket und andere
urlaubsinsel nun vorsichtig geöffnet
obwohl landesweit die korona zahlen
wieder stark ansteigen
die whites sind weltgewandte walliser
arbeiten als lehrer in dubai und haben
den hotelpool heute ganz für sich
was einerseits am geringen
gästeaufkommen andererseits aber auch am
sturmtief liegt das sich über der
tropeninsel festgesetzt hat
was klar aber die gelegenheit gibt den
täglichen formular krieg zu führen den
das sandkasten projekt den touristen
abverlangt diese vordrucke hier müssen
wir täglich auswählen und auf listen ob
wir irgendwelche symptome bemerkt haben
und das geben wir am schluss ab und hier
nochmal das gleiche eine selbstauskunft
umständlich und auch zeitraubend aber
die whites sind einverstanden mit den
maßnahmen wenn es zu streng wäre oder zu
riskant für uns dann werden wir nicht
gekommen
und wir haben auch immer die
infektionszahlen im blick diese den
pocket sehr niedrig es mussten sich ja
alle vor allem die hotelmitarbeiter
impfen lassen
und dann ist da noch die nachverfolgung
sap die ihre träger vor
infektionsgefahren soll und die alle
ihre bewegungen überwacht und weiter
meldet aber allzu groß dürfte der
bewegungsdrang wohl nicht sein denn
anderthalb jahre ohne touristen haben
phuket nicht gut getan
[Musik]
gut ein drittel aller betriebe sollen
dicht gemacht haben aber wer durch die
ödnis des einst quirligen strand
viertels paton fährt dem mag das noch
untertrieben erscheinen bars massage
wechselstube restaurant und souvenirshop
verriegelt und verrammelt und mickys
gästehaus verdankt sein überleben nicht
den wenigen treuen kunden sondern der
verzweiflung der wirtin
die behörden haben wir empfohlen das
lokal zu schließen bis alles sich wieder
erholt aber wenn ich zu machen
dann habe ich doch nichts mehr aus der
tiefsten provinz war sie nach phuket
gekommen
in der pandemie verlor sie ihren job als
köchin aufgeben aber wollten mit ihm
nicht und setzte alles auf eine karte
ein eigenes lokal mit fremden betten
irgendwann würde corona ja vorbei sein
aber corona blieb gäste blieben aus und
nur die schulden wuchsen von der
regierung gab es keinerlei unterstützung
für die alleinerziehende mutter
ich wollte meine familie stolz machen
darauf dass ich etwas aufgebaut habe ich
werde bald 40 andere in meinem alter
haben so viel und ich habe nichts ich
will doch nicht als versagerin enden
aber es ist ja nicht so als wäre ich 25
und könnte morgen noch mal ganz neu
anfangen
am absoluten tiefpunkt verfasste sie
sogar einen abschiedsbrief an ihre
eltern aber dann beschloss sie doch
weiter zu kämpfen
ob das sand boxprojekt sie nun retten
kann
von dieser öffnung profitieren erstmal
nur die großen hotels und die
restaurants mit amtlichen siegel mein
lokal liegt in einer hintergasse und
keiner würde vom strand so weit laufen
um hier zu essen
meine einzige hoffnung ist dass ich doch
mal ein gast hierher verirrt jeder
geschlossene laden jede lehre biertheke
in karton erzählt eine ähnliche
geschichte auch in phuket elefanten camp
hoffen sie auf die rückkehr der
touristen manager urs fehr konnte nur
mit seiner schweizerischen findigkeit
den bankrott abwenden
die tiere verdauen nun hauptberuflich
kaffeebohnen nach der veredelung im
dickhäuter darm soll die rüstung
deutlich aromatischer schmecken
das ist ein produkt das sehr gesucht ist
es gibt sehr wenig auf der welt ist sehr
kostspielig auch mal verdient sehr gut
damit
und dass ich die hoffnung dass wir
überleben können ein besuch bei den
elefanten steht natürlich auch auf dem
programm der familie weit aus dem
trockenen dubai für die geht es aber nun
erst mal runter zum sturm brausten
strang
ich glaube die beiden genießen es
wirklich sie gegen den regen
das ist für sie jetzt erst mal das
größte sie haben ja seit zwei jahren in
dubai kein tropfen regen gesehen
so bekommt jeder das nach was er sich
sehnt in der sandkiste von phuket und
die anderen können zumindest hoffen
[Musik]